[Music]
they mr. wonderful here and welcome to
the beachside edition of ask mr. boffin
now look you know there's so many
fantastic questions that comes through
the transom in the last couple of weeks
but I was gonna wait to like I'm a
studio and do it in there but I thought
look there is no rest for the weary and
I want to get to some of these questions
that they're absolutely fantastic so
yeah we're on the beach let me show you
some of the accoutrement sere
this is a biodegradable straw by the way
check this guy out with your little arm
oh I like that
mmm coconut juice so healthy just love
it anyways look let's skip to the
questions some very interesting stuff
has come over and what I really like
about this this week's version is so
many international questions like you
name it all around the globe and I think
what's great about entrepreneurs and
people that want to work and you know
everybody wants to start a business and
all these questions they're the same
required will subgenre be regardless of
language we're all in this journey
together and so I think it's great that
we share the style of so let's get right
to the top of this I have a question
from Allison which I really like
let's hear it all right Alice what do
you got hello I'm so glad you're doing
this many Pelisson and I live in Utah
and I have question my husband and I are
52 years old and we have a 11 year old
and a fortune year old we had kids a
little bit late due to our choices and
various circumstances beyond our control
we don't have anything for retirement I
might have about a little bit from about
nine years for Tina's state employee um
I work part-time my husband works
full-time he makes about 85,000 to
90,000 a year I make about 25 thousand a
year I would like to see raise my kids
stay home with them as much as possible
and we would like to know some
suggestions for fast-track to retirement
our house is we are on our house paid
off 14 over $1400 a month for that
Allison this is a fantastic question and
you know it's the essence of everybody's
challenge so let's talk about it you got
kids it sounds like you're happily
married now here's the good news the
average salary in America is about 56
thousand dollars so you're making over
almost 120,000 combined between your
part-time gig and what your husband is
doing but let me tell you what the core
to this issue is and believe me I don't
care how rich you are it's the same
problem everywhere
people buy too much crap I'm guilty of
it you're guilty of it
believe me it's happening what you're
gonna have to do if you want to prepare
for time because you're basically
telling me you don't have any dough set
aside that's a big problem so you're
gonna have to actually save fifteen
percent of what you're bringing in every
month which means you have to stop
buying crap there's crap you bought
yesterday you don't need I've been
saying this for years look in your
closet of all the clothes and shoes you
don't wear come on your husband's got
the same thing going on it's not that
hard to cut the crap out every time
you're gonna buy something Alison ask
yourself right there in that moment do I
really need this crap and the answer is
90% of the time No so that's the first
thing that's gonna happen you got to
raise your kids so you can't cut back on
school and you tacked up back on good
food for them but there's so much crap
you don't need to do and I know I'm
right and you know I'm right so for all
of you out there to listen to this and
Alison raised this question she's the
right one to ask it you got to just cut
it back and then you take that 50% and
you buy a bunch of ETF's
you can go online now and set up an
account for free and some of these
online brokers and just buy an
exchange-traded fund you just buy the
market it's gonna give you 6 to 7% a
year which is gonna be great for you as
you put this money aside for the next 15
to 20 years Alison that's what you're
gonna live on anyways I'm glad we met
but to everybody who's listening to this
today from now on when you walk outside
and you get out there and you see
something in a store what do you want no
my friends do not buy that crap I have
been able to train myself to cut back on
that on everything except watches that's
the only thing I'm weak at and it's a
horrible horrible disease I have but
everything else I don't buy that crap ok
on the watches I got it but some of
those I deserve I work hard but on the
rest of that crap and my kids and my
wife - no crap zero crap that's how you
save money
all right let's move on here let's go to
Denis all right Denis what do you got
hi mr. wonderful my name is Denise
Onyango from Kenya earliest Africa cool
my question to you is this what's your
take on forex trading I tend to see it
as gambling I could be wrong please let
me know what do you think Thank You
Dennis - Kenya you basically asked the
question about FX trading that's
currency trading now let me tell you why
that is so solely personal currencies
fluctuate against each other all day
long a lot of people don't know this the
largest market in the world is the
currency market it's huge
trillions of dollars nobody makes money
trading it it's almost impossible a few
years ago the Swiss franc almost doubled
against the US dollar nobody saw it
coming so many people are wiped out
we're trying to catch that trade as they
like to say that is when you are trading
currencies you are basically speculating
you're taking huge risk
I am completely against it I have some
currencies in my investments have Swiss
francs British browse euros American
dollars Canadian dollars but I keep them
in a ratio
I don't trade them I don't know what's
gonna happen with any of those curses
any one time so I'm totally against that
that's for sure so that's the right
question do I think it's a good idea to
invest in no I'm more conservative give
me a companies pay me a two or three
percent dividend when we grow earnings
over time I use ETS for that stuff now
but FX trading or currency trading no no
Nanette I hate it
although a great question and I'll love
the Kenya connection ask mr. wonderful
is going global
now click break let's go check out the
beach what's happening here
all ya kiddies that is so nice
you know the sound of the waves is so
peaceful I just love it something about
the Sun the sand and the water and it's
just great to be able to talk to each
other while we hear the waves crashing
in each well I've had a number that's
wonderful
I'll get back to work here we go
let's get to the next question
all right yeah this one is from Jack
let's hear it jack
I'll cool it on the birds alright so
back Alfred Hitchcock menu how do you
stay motivated stay conflation yourself
and how do you stay happy third
sometimes
Jack what a deep question
how do you stay motivated confiden
yourself and stay happy I love it I'm
glad you raised it let's talk about that
nobody's happy a hundred percent of the
time that's not how life works my
friends it just doesn't work that way
but you know you got to get up in the
morning and ask yourself what can I do
today it solves four three problems for
me one most of us are working I'm gonna
be working until I drop dead so I want
to get something done towards that how
can I do something for my family because
family first all the time what can you
do at your family and if you're married
or living with your significant other
what can I do to help them because a
happy significant other you know the
happy wife happy life well these days
happy significant other happy life so
you got to balance all these three
things with your day you gotta take care
of who you're living with you gotta take
care of your family you gotta take care
of your business and when you're doing
these things you're gonna find that they
eat up sixty seventy percent of your day
if your mind goes idles sometimes you
can get depressed it's happened to me
too you know things get on my mind I
can't sleep I worry about it it's the
wrong thing to do you've got to think
big picture happiness is so hard to
pursue in anybody that tells you they're
happy 100% of the time is full of [ __ ]
that is so not true
everybody deals your stress regardless
of your situation I have people that are
friends of mine that are incredibly
wealthy and they're miserable I know
people that are struggling financially
and are happy with their families so
there's nothing to do with money
happiness it's not a destination it's a
journey every day is different and life
is gonna throw you some crazy stuff
remember this conversation when it
happens stay focused don't go nuts try
and stay focused on the things that
matter in your life your job your family
those are basically it and the things
you love you know if you love to play
music you love art you gotta spend some
time with that too
anyways you know I feel like I'm gonna
cry or something here you're getting
emotional with this one but it really is
all about what is life about well in
life is about being happy you got to
find that what makes you happy who knows
gee it was a great question
alright let's move on here I like that
one
now we'll go to the 7-eleven yes okay
that was never going to Catherine tell
you Jack I love members so Katherine
Scott
good morning mr. Wonderful's I have a
question my name is Katherine Sarah mana
I'm from Trail British Columbia Canada
and I was wondering if you would ever
consider becoming the Prime Minister of
Canada I think that you would be a great
Prime Minister I don't really know you
very much but I seen a few of your
videos on LinkedIn and you seem pretty
positive upbuilding very nice man all
over how the hell nted and worldly and
it seemed like the perfect Prime
Minister and it would be so great if you
did I think you could win I would vote
for you
I've only voted boys in my life and I'm
58 and I think it would be great because
I love President Trump and I hope that
he runs for office forever I think that
YouTube would make a great North America
god bless you Wow Catherine Catherine
that was really really cool you know mr.
wonderful for Prime Minister I have to
be honest with you though I tried that
once already and I got my pass handed to
me politics is really tough I'm still
paying for it but listen I love the
question you know sometimes you find in
your life a time to serve your country
and I think it's a very noble thing to
do but politics is not like business
it's nasty stuff and I'm glad I gave it
a try and I learned so much about it but
and I never say never to anything you
don't know what life is gonna bring but
I love helping launch
I love starting businesses and helping
people grow them that's what I'm good at
and that's what I want to do and I got
that bug of public service and
originally my wife said to me you're
crazy to try it and then when you got
into the game she said I'm proud you're
doing it and then when I lost you said
hey bozo why'd you waste all that money
so you know that's basically what
happens is it's a risk but I think
politicians I would prefer just
generally speak and you talked about the
US and Canada and Mexico now we got the
NAFTA thing coming should all come from
business that's how I view it because
then they experience what it takes to
create a job and in the end of the day
that's what makes a country great any
country entrepreneurs starting
businesses creating jobs regardless of
what party in which the politics are
who's against job creation nobody and I
think that's what's wonderful about
politics if you can actually bring it to
the table and help people grow
businesses that's cool but thanks for
that question and I'd you know I'm
flattered but I'm just absolutely
flattered I love that that you think I
would be a good leader I think that's
kind of cool they say that business
leadership doesn't translate the
politics I say finish it anyways that's
my two cents let's get another one in
here I'm loving these questions here we
go
and oh this is interesting
Nicola let's find out with Nicole is
real all right hit me Nicola
hello this is Nico from Poland we have a
project in Poland in a clinical waste
recycling we want to do finance it's a
starter do you please tell me what would
be the best way to get financed for that
project thank you I love it
once again as mr. wonderful goes global
that was from the cola in Poland
once the finance something to do with
recycling anything to do with recycling
is an interest to every government on
earth today so the first place I'd go to
get financed is look at government
programs including a : that want to help
startups that are trying to improve the
environment that's the first place why
it's the cheapest cost of capital when
you get money from the government it's a
lot cheaper than the private sector and
they already have a mandate they
basically taking your tax dollars and
recycling it into the economy to try and
help people get more stuff done around
recycling in the environment of course
it makes sense so we call it my answer
that question is go online check your
own government programs and you're gonna
find somebody somewhere in one of those
ministry that wants to help your
business you sound like a sharp guy now
get to work and make it happen then
after you prove out the model you can
say it'll be profitable then you go to
the private sector then the Capitals
allow 0 that's how it works you know
thank you that question a quick break
here and I go to my oh yeah
a little coconut with an aggressive
mm-hmm it's delicioso
coconut water so healthy for you the
umbrella keeps it cool from the heavy
Sun hitting the water in the coconut
plus the coconut is a natural insulator
who knew right you learn these things on
the beach let's move on let's get
another question here well by the way I
want to show you this t-shirt I'm
wearing you see what it says as you back
a little bit this is a t-shirt from my
new collection this is the cold hard
truth I don't know when the guys that
are making this thing are going to bring
it out but it's very cool it'll actually
do something that we could do together
maybe I'll do a limited run of it's kind
of an ask mr. wonderful thing but I like
this whole t-shirt thing and of course
these guys are great entrepreneurs so
I'm gonna help them out let's get the
next question let's see what we got here
alright
Sharon coming up all right Karen hit me
what do we got here Gary my question to
you is what is the three businesses /
ideas did you see will change and
completely revolutionize the way we
operate and working assumption in the
next decade
what would we those three versus what
would be the three on my mean / problems
begging for solutions less you mean
sister investing in and just a very big
fan of yours love how stupid romantic
and I'm gonna take you out through
investments in us thank you very much
another global question from London
England that was really cool so I like
it
I thought it was character such that
Kareem but anyways great questions one
of my top three ideas well they happen
we start 10 companies so the one that I
think is the most intriguing is a
company called blue land now this is the
ceramic bottle there's a blue land
bottle and this is actually a little
capsule if you put in it so you don't
have to lug two pounds of water from the
grocery store and you don't throw the
plastic out into the ocean afterwards so
these guys have got a patent to
crystalize cleaning liquids very cool
company as a matter of fact I love the
question gonna roll the commercial check
this out to get an idea of what they do
introducing blue land the better way to
clean our reusable bottles and
revolutionary tablets transform water
into a powerful cleaning solution
with blue lands cleaning is easy and
good for the planet
our non-toxic formulas are proven to
work better than the leading brands and
you'll never throw away another plastic
cleaning bottle so clean your home with
blue land and clean the world
get your kit today at blue landcom
that's number one number two which i
think is going to be a global winner is
this product here called Benji Locke
this is the first lock in the world to
have a key in it see that and have a
fingerprint pad that lets you open the
lock with your fingerprint on it very
very cool and then number three which
you know maybe it's not a world beater
but it's really really cool and I use it
every day check this out this is a
bottle of boost oxygen yeah yeah 95
percent oxygen so kind of sharpens your
mind a little bit particularly when you
getting tough questions like this one
from London England very cool product
another shark tank deal now you can't
ship boost by air because it's
compressed oxygen so it's got to go by
ground that's one of the challenges the
company has but I think we're gonna hit
50 million in sales this year so it's
still an okay anyways all these products
are online check them out yeah I'm
shamelessly promoting them but you asked
me for game changes I just gave you
three great ones let's do one more
question
each see.well occurred on but I'm really
you know I'm really enjoying this this
week's version of ask mr. wonderful more
sip this one isn't the token of
something else never
skee you know it's a skinny margarita I
can't stand the sugars and those things
but anyways it's got the salt around the
rim I like it let's go here to grace hi
grace here we go one more question
hello Kevin my name is grace Calavera
and I am seeking for your advice
my husband and I came legally to the
United States as part of a relocation
program for a company and we both work
for a full time for an IT fortune 500
company we came with two suitcases in
our hands and started from scratch in
this country we have filled the family
with two kids already
my background is administration and my
husband is an IT engineer we have to
penalize over 50k and we really don't
know what to do with it we have thought
about putting our business before
investing the money in the market but we
just really don't know what to do with
it we would really like you to
eventually quit our jobs or your own
bosses
or even better if we could have our
money work for us I would really
appreciate your advice on what to do
with or capitalized money thank you so
much gaming for your time
race you are the backbone of America
just like me
I'm half Lebanese half Irish and you
obviously have the work ethic about the
$50,000 set aside the key to this
journey particularly to build that
family pillar around Finance is to save
it and invest in marketing gets you
about six or seven percent I say this
all the time you want to take it's gonna
be a little conservative because Marcus
had a great run the last couple of years
so you want to make me put a third of it
to work I like to use ETFs I use these
online brokers that are free low cost
low Commission all of them no matter
which one you choose give it by so you
can just you know go online and have a
dialogue with them and say look I want
to buy a couple of ETFs for long-term
investing maybe of that 50k maybe put a
third of it to work but be very
conservative if you can make six or
seven percent on that that's great but
the key to success for your husband and
you to believe me I say this to
everybody is to keep 10% of your
after-tax income each year and investing
that way for the next 20 years
you're gonna end up in a great place an
absolutely great place it's all about
Family Values it's not you know family
is about let's say you say to me well
it's not about love no a family is
actually a business it's love is
important got to have that but you're
actually building a financial pillar
that you can support a family with and
that means you've got to save you have
to have economic goals it sounds like in
your case both of you came over the
United States got jobs that's fantastic
now you got to go to work but you sound
driven but the end of the day you're
building a family and then later in life
you can be a provider and help your
children launch and then they provide
for their family the cycle of life what
a great way to end this week's ask mr.
wonderful I just feel exhilarated partly
because the questions were so fantastic
[Music]
[Music]
some movie